die weißrussische oppositionsführer in
maria kein isny cover ist nach bild
-informationen entführt worden bei mir
im studio jetzt meine kollegin jasmin
joghurts du warst die vergangenen wochen
für uns in weißrussland hat dort die
demonstrationen verfolgt jetzt ist die
oppositionsführung verschleppt worden
was genau gibt es bereits für
informationen genau also die am
weißrussischen medien berichten dass cal
essen cover also die oppositionsführerin
die letzte die noch dort war um 10 uhr
weißrussischer zeit verschleppt wurde
und zwar in der nähe des kunstmuseums
dort sie war wohl auf dem weg zur post
die da in der nähe ist und wollte
eigentlich ein paket abholen
da ist ihr daneben ein lieferwagen
aufgelauert mit der mit der aufschrift
kommunikation drauf und hat sie dann
eben in diesen in diesem wagen gezerrt
und ist weggefahren
das alles wurde von der polizei nicht
bestätigt sondern die am berufen sich
darauf eine augenzeugin die das alles
eben gesehen hat und auch wohl gesehen
hat wie das handy noch hinfiel und genau
quietschende reifen im prinzip hätte was
gerade gesagt sie war die letzte
position führen die noch im land war das
bedeutet dass jetzt also für
weißrussland und warum ist das genau
jetzt passiert ja also für lukaschenko
zeigt sich natürlich in den letzten
wochen vier wochen lang gingen die
proteste dort weiter sie war sozusagen
das gesicht der friedlichen proteste und
ein diktator kann und so was natürlich
nicht leben
so hätte glaube ich auch nicht gedacht
nach dass nach diesen ganzen festnahmen
nach nach allem was eben vor ort war
weiterhin friedliche proteste dort
stattfinden und immer weiter gehen und
muss natürlich irgendwie dem dem den
gräben ausmachen und das kann man
natürlich nur wenn man das gesicht die
oppositionsführerin eben stoppt also er
hat wohl auch am 14 september laut
russischen medien noch eine
ein gespräch mit putin vor ort und auch
da will er natürlich zeigen dass er
weiterhin der harte diktator ist er
einfach nicht einsieht dass seine zeit
vorbei ist und eben dort auf auf die
hoffnung putins wartet und so jetzt muss
man aber auch sagen normalerweise bei
einer führung würde man sagen die
polizei muss sich jetzt darum kümmern
wie schätzt du dass man in weißrussland
ein die polizei steht natürlich hinter
lukaschenko wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass man jetzt schnellstmöglich durch
die hilfe der polizei in der der
staatlichen behörden die
oppositionsführerin wiederfindet das ist
eine schwierige frage also ich glaube ja
ich glaube nicht dass die polizei da
jetzt schnell etwas tun wird und alles
daran setzt eben die oppositionsführerin
wiederzufinden
der fall wurde der polizei eben gemeldet
sie gilt auch weiterhin als vermisst die
polizei hat bisher auch keine infos
rausgegeben und dadurch dass sie ebenso
wie so lukas schenk untersteht
es ist glaube ich sehr schwierig zu
sagen dass klasnic aber schnellstmöglich
gefunden werden sollen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren